okay so we're black and let's play
something a little bit different
let's play a knight or
[Music]
okay so he goes bishop c4
now you guys already know the drill okay
great example of
how to react he wants to intimidate us
knight h3 what should we do here
so normally we go e6 but here let's
modify our strategy a little bit
we don't have to go e6 immediately what
can we do first
first we can develop how
we don't need to go h6 we don't need to
stop the knife from coming to g5 we
don't need to be afraid of that
let's just go knight f6
simply knight f6 we don't need to do
anything crazy
and uh here we can go either d5 or e6
but
we've mostly been preparing the move d5
so let's do this
ladies and gentlemen takes and what
should we do now
and this really emphasizes how crappy
his opening idea has been
i see e6 but you guys are missing
something we should take the knight
don't forget he's put a knight on h3 we
should take the knight and as i always
say in these situations
it's not to ruin his pawn structure it's
in order
to ruin his king side so that we can
attack his king that's the main
rationale it's not about his pawns not
looking pretty
so we can
castle long here but one of the biggest
misconceptions i want people to take out
of their minds
is that you have to castle long in order
to cast in order to attack on the king's
side that's not true we can castle this
way
and i guarantee you guys that we can
still attack on this side of the board
and i will show you how
now attacking is misunderstood because
in order to attack
the key element is we need to bring our
pieces into the game no attack is going
to happen unless
we have active pieces so let's activate
our pieces one by one
and there's many ways of doing that
what i like is to get the rook to the
open file this is the most flexible
we're not committing to a position of
the queen yet
and now we can do what i call carving
out there is a square which we can carve
out for our knight who can tell me what
i mean by that i've already illustrated
the concept of carving out
so you guys should be familiar with this
term
and if you look at the center very
carefully we can see that the e4 square
is a prime real estate for the knight if
we go d4
he goes e4 c4 and he stops our knife
from getting to d5 thank you your knock
but we can go c4 and he has no
equivalent because the e4 square is
going to be weakened
but before we put our knight to e4 and
yes we're going to sacrifice upon
what should we do first we don't we
don't rush
we first ask okay how has the position
changed aha
this diagonal has opened so we can
activate our bishop first with a check
and here's the thing we're actually
going to take the pawn on c4
this is not an easy move to explain why
why am i not playing 94 well part of the
reason
is that i want to open up that d file
first
and we can reap the rewards of that
immediately with what move
and this move is going to be quite
devastating now
what move can we play let's get this guy
over here
and this game is over um he's look at
his position he's underdeveloped
and he's gonna get absolutely destroyed
here
and and i will explain the logic behind
that after the game i know that it might
seem weird why didn't we put the 94 even
though i said we would do that we might
still do that
but um this was a much better execution
of the idea
okay 92 is the only move
thank you jose joss pam in the chat
the man himself absolute beast
appreciate it
now how do we think about this position
well the rook on f1 if we take it
it'll be checkmate so the problem is the
knight is defending that rogue
our sort of default pattern
recognition should be can we undermine
this knight can we make it
move yes we can we can play knight e4
bishop b3 would have also been possible
but it's better to do this by activating
simultaneously as many pieces as
we can
okay what should we do now
let's not panic um oh my god we have a
we have a very cool idea here but with
no need for any fanciness we can simply
go queen to e2
and we reinforce the idea right if he
takes the knight we can still take the
rook
the game is over everything is hanging
we're threatening 50 different
checkmates
it depends what he does but these are
the consequences of not developing your
pieces
at a fundamental level it doesn't matter
if you're 2000 or 500.
the cool idea was knight g3 check but it
gets a little bit chaotic there
the cool idea i don't think oh shoot
i think it did work but it was a long
line
oh that would have been pretty sexy no
but i'll show you guys the whole
sequence
and it's a little hard to follow trust
me on that one
okay thank you and goodbye
absolutely i'll show you guys do i ever
not show you
cool ideas do i ever not show you cool
ideas
okay here's lines okay
obviously knight h3 was just dumb i i
have no idea where he got this from
and and we shouldn't be deterred by
moves like these
so knight f6 right uh the reason
after knight f3 that we don't play
knight f6 is well we actually can but
he's got e5
whereas here e5 is not
uh not possible all right you guys can
hear the sound right
yeah okay so d3 e6
castles d5 all very simple bishop takes
h3 right that's the key
key idea a bishop d6 here is tempting
but not as good because he can give a
check
don't forget that when we play d5 we
open up the e5
okay so castles here we play rookie
eight
and here the fun starts
and the move d4 is correct in its
intention
and um knight d5 is a good idea but he
plays c4 remember to always check for
these kinds of moves
and he deprives our knight of this
square
and that's why we play c4 because we're
almost guaranteed to have access to this
square so d takes c4 bishop c5
activating the bishop first and now the
move d takes c4 very important
um knight e4 first of all would have
been
very much possible black is still better
here i have no doubt about that
but d takes c4 opens up the maximum
amount of
real estate in the center and in a
position like this
which has such a big disparity in
development
uh it's not even about putting your
pieces on good squares so much as it is
about
opening up the position as much as
possible thank you calhour and riera for
the primes
okay uh and patience is also very
important here
we don't need to rush with any
particular move in this position
we will get our pieces to the good
squares you need to trust
in the potential energy of your pieces
and you want to make sure that when
you're actually cashing in you've
probably heard the expression
the threat is stronger than its
execution and what i see a lot of people
do is they they notice a good square for
a piece and they immediately put it
there they put their head down
it's a form of tunnel vision at a high
level but by not rushing
we are able to ensure that when we do
play knight e4
94 which happened here it comes with
maximum effect
because we've opened up this avenue for
the queen i don't know if that makes
sense
maybe i'm talking too generally but
that's sort of the rationale
behind the movie takes you for it it's
actually nothing to do with us trying to
like not lose upon
that's completely not the idea the idea
is to open up this pathway for the queen
it just visually opens everything
exactly so
our bishop is hanging but so is the rook
um 9294 undermining the knight and in
this
position we had a very sexy idea how did
i find this idea
the first thing i noticed is that i
really want the rook to be on e1
because that could create the potential
for checkmate so logically speaking
we want to move the knight away with
check um
and knight g3 check accomplishes that
task even if it
sacrifices the knight to two pieces now
he takes either way
he loses rookie one that's kind of cool
queen e2 and this is going to be
checkmate in a couple moves
if he plays um brook takes g3
it's the same exact thing check and
checkmate
but the reason i rejected this is
because he can play king gt using this
knight
as a pathway to escape to g3 but i
calculated this a little bit further
rookie two check
king takes g3 this is where i stopped
calculating initially but afterward i
realized that black is a very sexy move
in this position
which uh you know i think allows the
attack to succeed could somebody spot it
we use the pin bishop f2 is correct
nicely done
rook cannot take the bishop because of
the pin if the king goes back
then we drop the bishop back with a
discover check shutting down its escape
to g3 and now you guys should be already
familiar with the checkmating pattern
rookie one
and queenie two cut bernie with a prime
let's get this hype train out of the
station appreciate it guys thank you so
much
if he goes forward then this is a
classic king hunt
i think there are several ways to give
checkmate one of them is to go h5
if king h5 then queen f5 is made
i call 15. if king g5 i'm sure we
probably have some sort of beautiful
mate
but f6 here is the sort of business
approach
i'm loving them too and queen f5 of
course he can give up
the queen on f6 curious chimpanzee here
we go five gifted
to the community thank you so much sorry
guys i didn't mean to do that thank you
so much curious chimpanzee let's check
with the computer
knight g3 was indeed winning
yep this was winning but queen e2 was
just as good
this is so overwhelming that it would
have been just as good thank you so much
curious chimpanzee
five gifted to the community um narrow
bridge swoops xc the prince the price
annie blasting and
dtp sun thank you so much
okay uh and after queen e2 the threats
against his king
are completely overwhelming and so he
plays queen c5 which technically is a
blunder but there's really no
nothing he can do he's completely
paralyzed we want to take
everything in the house okay
and that's all there is to it that's all
there is to the attack that we that we
conducted
okay what is the move that made him lose
well i already think knight hd set him
up for failure
and i think that in this position he's
much worse
i mean honestly i think that the fact
that he took on d5
is a big reason why he lost he he should
not have taken on d5 he should have
played bishop e5
and bit the bullet and uh
the reality is if i if i grab the pawn
too quickly
thank you gigahertz then you know he can
play knight g5 and he can sort of
worm his way around the edges and try to
get some compensation i wouldn't have
done that
the very least white is somewhat in the
game
uh i almost think that by giving me the
opportunity to take on h3
uh my advantage ballooned to almost
decisive proportions
holy smokes this is the same ending leo
origami
five gifted to the community let's go
like water triple one quadruple one
flash
leaky faded killer cast tv and hey
it's red fox getting subscriptions let's
go appreciate it guys thank you so much
raising my tea too to this incredible
support
damn girl
okay um any questions as
slain priman
how did you conclude teddy for oh my god
all right guys this is the famed 3am
hype
because we got reality pizzas five more
subs
to the community holy smokes bruges law
batch funk lewnewski earl meister
unbelievable
thank you so much reality pizzas you
guys are
unbelievably generous at all hours of
the day that's what this is showing
amazing uh any questions
um well chestable and chess space are
different
things if you didn't take your c4 pawn
what was the idea to open the center
well you know that probably would have
been
what he should have done he probably
shouldn't have taken the pawn
but if he had gone d4 then i would have
occupied this beautiful outpost
and it's okay i would have used the
e-file i would have used the e-file
you know it's not as wide of an expanse
as the whole center
but with how weak his position is i
think this would have been enough
uh thank you chance 10 10 by 10 i
appreciate it
okay um any other questions about this
game
p pal 14 300 bits
oh jp wagoner
let's go five more gifted from the
community
this never ends music by jbm a thousand
bits by channel no
wow there's definitely an encore now
jp wagon are five gifted over two
thousand viewers lots of hype
at this ungodly hour as music by jbm
yep amazing
well i'm just sipping my tea watching
people go crazy
all right you're getting an encore
that's for sure
so let's get the next game underway one
moment
yeah i know there's this is a mix of
like lemongrass ginger and
some other herbal tea good thing before
bedtime
we're over 5400 subs incredible stuff
cannot believe it my game tomorrow is at
5 00 p.m eastern don't worry guys
i'll be fine i'll be fine i'm always
so hyped at the speed run and uh i
really enjoy myself i'm in the moment
and how could i not with this level of
generosity honestly
100 bits thank you the real mr perrick
no everything is appreciated let's get
underway
neck 310 of the prime let's go
300 bits by chance 10 by 10
and dober okay another e4 okay he plays
the alakan defense
which we respond with with e5
and in the yala kind okay the movie six
is uh is not the best i'll talk a little
bit about this opening
afterward and what do we want to do if
we're white here
as i've explained several times when our
opponent plays an opening like this
there's always a temptation to grab as
much of the center
as possible thank you but that's
something that i
that i that i recommend people to
sometimes avoid
you want to get some of the center so
here we want to go c4
and he's disconnected we want to chase
the knight away from d5 but
i wouldn't recommend going f4 although
that is a legitimate move after we go c4
we want to make sure that we develop our
pieces
uh in such a way that we protect the
center that we've claimed right it's
almost like we've
bitten off this big chunk and then we
need to bring our pieces in
so that we developed them and this move
was so strong
what a game that was an incredible game
wow
so strong that he literally disconnects
his isb
is beyond impressed with me right now
yeah unfortunate that he disconnected
but
this gives me a chance to quackhead
getting the sub
and my lands leonard totor12 gift
getting a sub as well
music by jbm with 100
the isp gambit is right
so the alakan gambit is very legit
stragility thank you for the two months
the alakan sorry not the alkyne game but
the alkyne is very much legit
and the alakan is part of the openings
that are called
hyper modern openings i've talked on
several occasions
about the history and the nature of
hyper modern openings
by and large they appeared around the
1920s by a group of players who
contested
the sort of conventional chess idea that
you have to control the center with your
pawns these are a group of players that
say
i don't think so you have to control the
center of your pawns to some degree
but what you can also do is you can
provoke your opponent into biting off
more than he can chew
you can provoke your opponent into
controlling the center with a million
pawns and then you can
snipe at these pawns with your pieces
the alakan belongs to that group of
openings
black literally almost forces white's
pawns
as far into the center as possible d4 c4
there is even f4 the four pawns attack
which is a very legitimate opening and
then
black finds ways to chip and crack away
at
that center yeah it is similar to the
nim switch so in the four pawns attack
for example
uh black can play c5 or
you know black and play uh knight c6 and
you guys can see that he's starting to
attack the pawns
with his pieces uh and
in the alakin that's why i said he
played e6 which is not as effective
because he's not immediately undermining
my pawns
and and so here for example i would not
have played f4 i would have instead
developed my pieces with knight c3 takes
and knight f3 rather than controlling
all of the center i would have
controlled some of the center enough to
give me a nice edge
and develop my pieces that's often how
you respond against these hyper modern
openings
now when you guys say the nimzovich is
that e4 knight c6
so the nimzovich is a different opening
right it there there is a difference
between
bringing the knight to f6 and c6 and
the biggest difference is that you know
white doesn't have the move e5
and the nimzovich often transposes to e4
e5
or you get a position like this this is
also a hyper modern opening but it's
more rare
this is considered a little bit more
dubious than the alkyne
now there are people in the 16 17 1800
rating range
to whom i do recommend the alakan i
think the alakan is a very legitimate
opening
if black plays it very well it's
actually not easy for white to prove
a big advantage it's actually not that
easy for white to prove an advantage at
all
and uh my good friend brian tillis
national master
is a very good opening analyst he's done
the chessable repertoire on the alakan
if you're looking into it
uh by all means check out his course
and i want to caution you guys as i have
in the past
i would say at least 1600 plus because
before
the principle i've talked about applies
uh and yeah if you play the alakan well
you can actually get
big advantages with black and there are
grand masters who played the alakan
as one of their main openings even peter
gionatus
who i crap on all the time but he's a
big alakan person and he's played it a
lot with great results
there's one thing i want to clarify for
you guys don't fall into the trap of
thinking
that just because an opening is not like
a tier because it's not e5 or c5 but
it's crap
this is not crap this is a very
legitimate opening and if you're playing
on the white side of it
you should not expect yourself to get a
winning position out of this opening
okay you should give a little bit more
respect to it uh and and that helps you
respond in a more measured way that's
exactly what
players want you to think they want you
to think ah this is this is total crap i
can just
you know control the center and i'm good
and you know before you know it
you you have a lost position so that
mentality i think in my opinion
is very very important to institute
correctly in your mind well the thing is
if black plays this correctly white's
not going to get a chance to just run
black off the board
uh you can see that c5 is not possible
here
and and d5 is not possible here so white
has to be a little bit more careful than
that
carlson has played it as well as you
guys know
okay um so so that's sort of a quick
rundown of the alakan can i play the
alakan in one of the games sure i'll
play it in the next game
since i've talked about the alakan and
such
in such um encouraging terms i
would be happy to give you guys a sense
of the alakan
myself so let's go right knight of six
that's a great idea actually thank you
okay so he plays d5 this is a serious
dude okay d6
and he goes bishop c4 so um
this is a slightly different way of
playing the alakan from white's
perspective he
uh prioritizes developing his pieces
rather than controlling the center with
his pawns
uh if i remember correctly there is a p
sacrifice
line here with bishop takes f7 although
i'm not sure this is here
let me think for a second so
i'm trying to remember okay so here's
what we're gonna do
because i'm a little bit worried there
is some sort of trap line i'm going to
protect that knight with my pawn
i'm going to play a little bit so
passive but solid
passive but solid and there's something
to be said for openings
where yes you're slightly worse you're
slightly passive but it's very hard to
break them now let's develop our knight
and attack the pawn on e5 let's force
him to decide
and after e takes d6 we're going to take
with our bishop now we're going to allow
him to play d4 he's going to have more
of the center than we do
that's okay because again we have very
very solid piece placement let's take on
e5 in order to pave away
the diagonal for our bishop potentially
look at how nicely our knight on d5 is
placed
nice solid knight where should we put
our bishop e7 or c5
it's a slight kind of trick question
actually
believe it or not it's a bit of a trick
question
in my opinion we should actually put the
bishop
on isab
why because if we put it on c5 we allow
his bishop or his knight
to get to the g5 square and that ladies
and gentlemen is how you play the alakan
defense and it wins the game by force
in eight moves
you can't make this stuff up i think it
only happens in this speed run
oh my lance
here come the hundred gifts of bums
after that game
i mean this is just absolute mastery
okay so i actually think that i didn't
play this the best way
let me actually check with a computer
here so i was a little bit concerned
about this move okay but that's actually
not a move
oh no it was just flicking g8
and now queen eight okay this is
actually not a thing sorry i
um i messed this up a little bit e6 is
not the best because it blocks the
development of our bishop
knight b6 is the best move and
then what we don't want to do is go
bishop g4
this would be a big mistake who can tell
me why this is a very typical tactic
we've seen this many times before
and um could somebody just remind me of
why this doesn't actually work it's
bishop f7 and knight g5
and he opens up the attack on the
bishops certainly don't do that
but um we play d6 which is solid knight
c6
d takes d takes bishop b7 and of course
bishop f4 is inexplicable
what should white have done uh instead
of this there are several ways that
white can play here what i would have
done is gone queen e2
and rook t1 trying to open up as much
pressure on the knight as possible
removing the knight from the board is
the key to the position for white
but white doesn't want to do it by
taking on d5 that would actually
get me a nice diagonal for my bishop so
you don't want to do it in the brute
force way
but by going queenie to rook d1 you
apply pressure on the knight and i think
white is definitely
in the driver's seat here i don't think
white is like winning or anything like
that
but uh white is is definitely
significantly better
uh in this position so that's why you
want to be careful in these openings you
don't want to play them without
proper knowledge thank you so much chest
dojo live party at 131 unfortunately i
was just about to end
i'm quite out of gas i've been doing the
speed run